pas de confinement mais un début de
couvre-feu avancé à 18 heures qui ne
fait visiblement pas l'unanimité chez
les mères des régions concernées depuis
l'annnonce du ministre de la santé
olivier véran certains édiles font
entendre leur colère comme ici à nancy
avec le maire de la ville mathieu klein
je n'espère qu'une chose c'est me
tromper j'espère que ce couvre feu sera
suffisant efficace j'ai simplement
aujourd'hui à l'épreuve de des échanges
quotidiens avec les médecins avec
l'hôpital le sentiment que c'est sans
doute insuffisants et trop tardif déçus
par les mesures annoncées
certains maires n'hésite pas à prendre
eux mêmes les choses en main pour lutter
contre la pandémie covit 19 à nice par
exemple le maire l'est républicain
christian estrosi a annoncé le lancement
d'une campagne de vaccination anticipée
dès ce mercredi
chaque territoire ayant sa spécificité
il se trouve que nous nous sommes
frontalier avec monaco avec l'italie
avec un aéroport qui est passé de 20
vols par jour à 120 vols
c'est à dire le niveau de 50 % de
fréquentation de décembre 2019
tout cela a ramené une circulation
importante du virus
tout comme nice la région du grand test
a également accéléré sa campagne de
vaccination elle débutera dès lundi 4
janvier
par ailleurs pour encourager leurs
concitoyens faire de même 200 maires
s'engagent à se faire vacciner
à l'origine de l'initiative le maire de
poissy karl olive qui souhaitent lutter
contre la défiance de nombreux français
face au vaccin
un travail pédagogique indispensable
puisque 40% des français sont encore
réticents à se faire immuniser et dans
le même temps seulement 40% d'entre eux
se disent prêts à se faire vacciner
selon les derniers chiffres de santé
publique france